welcome to this video playing webmaster
Julian Hodgson again and his old opening
again here was the Javan Incas laughs so
let's see what kind of sloth we get and
that do I have an interesting idea
against this may be with and probably
still playing that he does g3 actually
found interesting let's see what he's
doing is taking the pawn ok now you can
go eat six yeah on g6 is interesting
also instead of e-cigs yeah that's
that's a good line for for black very
very playable um dragon me try to
remember this there was a chrome league
game against loop machine yeah forgotten
it I think romney just canceled takes
Knight eggs and yeah what about this
really yeah don't know can i play 95
here that is often a way to play and
this type of setup a four day six is not
usually played safe and have the night
here on c3 hmm interesting 95 CD 496 bc
bishops is six Bishop d7 a that's
probably probably good for luck
okay this should be three years going
Knight g4 probably mmm and how do i but
how do i get the pawn back if I take it
I don't see it okay nevertheless I don't
see it as don't see another move CD
knight c6 bc bishop c6 Bishop d7 Bishop
takes a 8 Queen a8 quindi for not liking
this very much but maybe ok I think
night xe5 should be quite comfortable
for me at least that's an interesting
middle game takes de 97 f 4 and have a
nice porn where Johnny 594 is completely
unplayable because of III hmm maybe
maybe it is playable because he's got
night be three available Knight d4 III
night somewhere there's Queen f-ed Queen
dat niet naar f7 winning the rook but on
94 III might have not be 3m is taking us
time but it's interesting an interesting
earlier complication I have spent two
minutes after nine moves and here he is
also approaching that that is also good
yeah an interesting move freely yeah
this keeps the pawn ha hmm
interesting should I go should be three
here maybe maybe attacking c5 and try to
accelerate my development and night be 3
i'm overlooking things here night b3
might be good also also this movement
interesting
yeah of course now if I take it takes
the the night that's unfortunate and f4
looks like complete nonsense yeah maybe
I need to
now it's good he's got might be three
all the time I but I can take see for
this might might be viable 9390 XC 4 9
a-1 d65 this could be compensation maybe
maybe it's not enough but it's
interesting well this will is almost
like a bullet game soon because we spent
so much time well we gotten again okay
so this one I penis 94 okay night b3 I
can take on c4 because night a1 there's
some I care that not really ok it's not
having any of that just not going with
this complications so should just move
the bishop away yeah I would have out of
this might be three business
maybe
now you might just just take on you fire
I mean back and play you 45 tricky very
tricky one minute ten ok I'm worse here
no question but it still feels like a
somewhat tricky position i have found
this pawn do in the center and still
he's got the nokia night b3 i have rook
s7 takes here ok any two I need to play
aggressively anyway some 95 is fine no 9
185 I guess but you can get something
going on there on the kingside take here
meow I guess I can take with the poor
now which I which I really forgot about
okay Wow take a five I cannot take here
I give five Wow um my daughter don't
really know very tough to play check
yeah yeah a long diagonal 29 seconds
that's not braid probably worse our lost
objectively but it still feels
complicated I thrown away threatens to
take care night of two
yeah this oops I don't understand I'll
take it oops I'd this one okay right age
six and night have sinus the the only /
hope i have in this position check check
wide for offense oh wow just when I'm
okay again am I not at night he 593 or
is it has he has he got a win I know
he's got to win should see success to
win okay covering this important square
so I don't get to f3 actually yeah okay
this reflects the the course of the game
maybe um yeah it was it was right tricky
right out of the opening very very
complicated well here I know that the
simple line is d takes d5 of course
takes my eggs and this is good for a
position where I'm why does pressing
with minimal risk but also it's not not
to do too much something like that is
how it is played check down later King
e7 but okay I wanted to play more
complicated but here I wasn't sure so
maybe I need to take then still need to
take her I don't own well okay this is
an interesting idea but Knight a5 was
very very tricky yeah probably that's
not great how I played there there were
multiple in multiple interests ring
interesting alternatives but came
yeah black is probably just better here
it's a pawn and very nice position on
the queenside i thought maybe i can i
can get something here but GF was a good
defense of course keeps this cupboard
and jam pewter is giving a black huge
scores check probably am i only have
some yeah maybe i have some swindling
chances here but okay it was it was
played with very little time you know
now thats that's just that's just toast
Angus yeah i didn't see that the rook
was saying this what's up i was
surprised yeah this is not they're not
the best but okay she was winning on
time anyway yeah interesting fight
thanks for watching